les réseaux sociaux sont parsemées de
pièges par exemple cette publicité on
vous propose un homme de fer décoratifs
pour le jardin regardez sa taille par
rapport aux chiens regardez maintenant
ce que des gens ont reçu pas mal plus
petit que prévu ce genre de piège des
courants sur internet et si vous avez
payé cet article avec paypal il ne sera
pas facile de vous faire rembourser
pourquoi parce que paypal exige que vous
retourniez la marchandise au vendeur
l'homme de fer est peut-être plus petit
que vous le pensiez mais le renvoyer en
chine à vos frais ça va vous coûter cher
les émetteurs de cartes de crédit euh
n'exige pas que les produits soient
retournés par exemple des jardins nous
affirme que dans la vaste majorité des
cas où la marchandise reçu n'est pas
telle que décrite le client est
remboursé mais selon paypal le
désavantage de la carte de crédit c'est
que vos informations financières sont
révélés au vendeur alors un truc
utilisez votre carte de crédit au lieu
de votre compte de banque comme source
de fonds pour payer avec paypal ainsi
paypal pérol vendeur puis porterait le
montant à votre carte vous aurez alors
meilleur des deux mondes quoique le muc
c'est peut-être finalement de ne pas
acheter ce genre de bébelles pensez vous
[Musique]